we like to mention that more about my
audition yeah it was Omar often I often
we do strange things for auditions but I
think your audition might be the
strangest thing I did you know I
prepared my lines for MIT and I went in
I did the scene he was brilliant and you
said thank you that was great now do it
as a wolf I'm like okay so all I did was
this was a wonderful experiences loving
me of you and I saw some of the concepts
art from the movie and it looks
incredible I can't wait for it okay so
sorry can I say Black Panther looks
insane dude looks amazing the trailer
was incredible
I felt oddly MOG you were in Tim
Burton's Planet of the Apes back in 2001
but there was no motion capture and that
was it no God never seen Tim Roth so
upset after sitting in makeup for five
hours kind of stroll in and say hey
what's going on guys laughter not to Don
but it was it was an amazing experience
working with him I say we kind of set
the franchise back a little bit you and
Rupert and revived it again which is
great it was obviously a big
intellectual property you use real
makeup yes but no but real not real
people although my real today the
monkeys would know they were the worst
they would attack you because they Helen
and I Helena Bonham Carter and I had
this relationship so I had to work with
the monkeys at the astronaut so they
wanted us to get acclimated with the
chimps and any time I would go near her
the chance to start attacking me and
start like trying to punch me in the
nuts like like really bad okay all right
stop it I'll stop playing around we got
to work and the chimps are constantly
trying to attack me because you had a
sort of similar experience and the zoo
didn't you well that was one that was on
King Kong yeah I did very sort of
long-standing affair with the gorilla
called Ziya about ten years ago and
she's lovely lovely gorilla and
and we hang out for a couple of months I
was observing her and we and we got you
know play games and sort of you know
with each other and it was all rather
lovely and then and then and then one
wife as you know it was yeah but
Lorraine my wife came down to visit and
you've got to come down and meet sy and
and and when when she came down
literally Ziya got this bottle of water
which has minerals and vitamins and she
just went live and sports was right
right in Ryan's face that's what she did
to me yeah
I guess so protected I really yeah and
territorial oh you talking about monkeys
yeah okay the other things with
chimpanzees do of course is a thing
called pants hooting which is when did
chips do that very exciting is that a
happy thing or a bad thing
apricot no it's a kind of territorial
thing of a kind and it's quite scary
yes defending territory okay I feel like
I've heard that sound yeah I'm sure you
have
[Music]
you